let me tell you something about the idol
what is this show new HBO show from Sam
Levinson Sam Levinson is the guy who
runs bro yeah Euphoria yeah absolutely
fantastic uh it's produced and starring
Johnny Depp's daughter Lily Rose Depp
and the weekend
a bunch of other famous actors in it as
well it's about this young
uh music pop star artist named Jocelyn
and uh she's just come off like a mental
breakdown or something she's about to
put out a new album whatever or new song
new sale come out anyway
um
the plot of the first episode
first of all before we even get to the
plot I get a text the thing comes on at
like nine o'clock
okay at nine and thirty seconds Vala is
already texting me son
Lily Rose death
crazy I'm like what's going on I don't
get to see until 11 o'clock bro the
opening scene
you shouldn't be able to be that skinny
and that heavy at the same time it's
like an optical illusion bro it's an
optical illusion
illusion but she's so heavy it's an
optical illusion bro it's an optical
illusion bro like I'm looking at her how
skinny she is but she's so heavy as
[__]
it's an optical illusion bro it's an
optical illusion though like Dr Uber
right right
illusion and I need some donations dude
I didn't know what to think I'd never
heard of this girl until Vala yesterday
Bala spread the word bro so I didn't
hear about her ball is like yo this girl
she's the one and I'm like
who is this I've never heard of her he
pulled her up pictures on Google don't
do it justice yo they're regular
schmegular on Google no disrespect Lily
Rose no all disrespect whoa Bros we got
a big up right now we're gonna objectify
this girl we're celebrating yes to her
and yeah disrespect to the photographers
to the photographer true true
angles bro bro
and the angle is Oliver straight on and
to the side bro there is a moment where
you see her nipples
[Laughter]
son she got she got this is gonna sound
crazy to say son real we might have to
I'm not I really did think I was in
chimp Empire for a second when I was
watching the show I put my Knuckles on
the bed what's going on I was like don't
worry about it
I started grabbing branches throwing
them all
bro the nipples
how'd you watch this with your shorty
though what like I gotta ask you
that's the nipple right there bro
bro
that had to be CGR
300 that had to be CGI yeah
[Laughter]
you gotta just find the scene go to the
scene I'm trying to find it I don't get
it because you see it's that heavy there
illusion
yo it might be angle to CGI because
we're looking at pictures
I need to put this on my lap bro
if we gonna watch that scene I need to
put this pillow on my lap how'd they get
heavier
with nothing else getting heavier no no
but she has body no she don't when she's
dancing outside
four four I'll know for you yeah for you
no
stop I'm used to the wagon that's what
I'm talking about
come on you know bumpers we do dumpers
over here come on for La for Beverly
Hills La where you were born and raised
yes for 16 year olds you think that that
is body but we're still off the nipples
she got two crickets coming out look at
them crickets look at them crickets bro
oh my God bro
times
come on bro look at the profile that
nipple look at that extension
she got a little toad come on bro
wow
wow that's an optical illusion that's an
optical illusion that has to be optical
illusion now that would shut that would
that would shoot straight through your
shirt
no questions
[Laughter]
all due respect she just hangs her
shirts all due respect with all due
respect to Johnny Depp with all due
respect to I can't even watch anymore is
that a gift
right there what does give stand for
[__] I'm not saying it
wow
there you go yes sir oh my goodness God
damn okay so what
oh so he has said it's the new Sydney
Sweeney oh but just less heavy and I was
like then it's nothing
[Laughter]
don't let them do it to you Sydney
Sweeney you are milk Queen number one
you're a milk Queen number one stop
being sexist over here
like we all not married I'm gonna drag
me into a single guy conversation
you started it dude it's an optical I'm
not even here man I was about to lick
your nipples [__]
but isn't the show that the girl gets
called don't get some smart [__] oh
no that wasn't smart
she got come down in the show okay the
plot of the show the plot of the show is
she gets [__] on in her face and took
a selfie of it and that goes viral
that's the plot for the first episode
and they show the picture of her getting
[__] on you know Sam Levinson Wild Boy
[__]
dude holy [__]
come on son it's great what's going on
like at what point is it just porn if
she's covered in [__] and is on the TV
and you're watching it alone that's real
life what do you mean at what part about
35 seconds this is at what part where my
[__] blanket was hopping up and down
left and right
guess what part are you kidding me no
are you kidding me oh my God I asked my
girls like what'd you do yesterday she
was like oh I watched the idol yeah she
watched it would like yeah why well
because I told my girl about it in the
morning and she managed within five
minutes to completely ruin Lily Rose
death for me I was like wow I just watch
the idols you're a very beautiful girl
the Sydney Sweeney didn't even do this
bro what'd you think was gonna happen I
know why you snitch on yourself Yo maybe
I didn't even say that
I probably said it another way oh I was
like yeah there's a very fast story over
at HBO between Cindy Sweeney and Lily
Rose and I'm feeling lactose in time
okay I just pulled my neck I'm from the
90s
listen there's another actress that's
going to make an appearance that is
so we wait till next week we don't want
to see that now yeah we do what does it
mean yeah selfie mud I mean that's a
fire name let's go baby
[Laughter]
listen this is with all due respect here
honestly what we're talking about right
now we're talking about no no okay can I
just clarify what we're talking about
right now we're talking about her
parents we don't even talk about her her
parents came together to create this
holy [__] that's what I'm saying
can I take your order
[Laughter]
no this is what is going on exactly
Sam Levinson needs a high five she's a
different hand it's like yeah it's like
Lefty you gotta go Lefty because my
right is sore it's like Sam Levinson and
then like Martin Luther King just like
right here
Martin Luther King Martin Luther King
like holy [__] God damn God
now he knows good TV why we get away
from it that's what I'm saying why'd we
ever get away from it damn he's a 90s
boy
son can I be objective here please
hurry up and get there
holy [__]
these young [__] got fat [__]
it is just I think it's the vaccine bro
I'll be honest with you Chili's like
this wasn't wasn't out in the 1990s it
wasn't out in the 2019 2020 to 2012 post
pandemic titties bro is that banana
bread they were eating it's it's the
vaccine it's the booster for them [__]
exonerated
she's been exonerated here we go
just trying to get everybody's more
calcium and vitamin D in this world we
need it she got Johnson and Johnson to
be honest with you they say is the
number one thing that protects you from
covid
vitamins
Jesus Christ she's looking still the
show but this is all due respect to her
family to put this together
that breeding put this together I don't
know how you grow your own titties out
no no I mean yes son you can't admire a
building without admiring the architect
there's something in the face it looks
ow ow we doing neck down today okay what
am I doing
work I don't know about the work
beautiful beautiful beautiful I'm sure
incredibly talented but with all due
respect she looked like a young Kate
Moss if he face think of young Kate Moss
in the big of a face hey look almost
like what did Kate Moss not have she had
that heroin Chic look but she did not
have the vaccines she didn't have them
vaccines
no no no no no no okay but what I you
know how we can look at a tall person we
could be like oh my God they're so tall
that's how we should be able to look at
these physical specimens these unique
physical specimens we have to be able to
admire an incredibly skinny girl with
huge fat [__] dumpster fire chips
Street like an old lady say oh you're so
to play basketball exactly
right so what should other people be
able to say about this no I'm not saying
that we should be able to go up to him
and just [__] Bruce him that's not
what we should be able to do I don't
think we should touch them I don't think
about it but to be able to talk about a
skinny girl that for whatever god-given
reason has
just a super
[__] [__] tits on her tits
I mean that is just so unique that we
must be able to talk about it we have to
reflect on it we would be inauthentic if
we weren't talking about them
we just appreciate in God right now
honestly
honestly why not okay he didn't get to
it no I did I did I did I did listen
who's seeing the show here I've seen it
you've seen it you see it no I haven't
no we're getting it what's it on brother
that's why they're so quiet yeah that's
why they don't know what's going on I
don't see the vision I don't know men of
culture listen I mean my girl describes
me exactly how you described it and so I
understand where she's coming from yeah
but I haven't seen it myself I mean the
last scene bro when he makes her Muslim
when he makes her a Muslim bride do you
remember that one oh my God who I
remember
oh gosh how's it a weekend yeah yeah
breathe breathe bro there's a scene in
it when she masturbates while choking
herself
yeah it was artistic yeah music is
beautiful shot yeah beautifully
beautiful yeah it was shot beautifully
yeah
it's real life [__] you don't choke
yourself
you don't do that that's not you that's
not your Tuesday bro but think about the
dexterity because a lot of people can't
rub their belly
yeah and then put pressure on my dick
but she was really getting in there I
wonder if they put a pad or something
because if she they didn't put a patch
she would definitely enjoy that method
acting Doug it might be method Avenue
yeah yeah yeah she does her own stunts
but she really she really does okay
um
can we talk about the story I don't even
know if we're there yet are you okay I
have to pee do you really yeah I have to
pee
I'll be back in about 90 seconds that's
all I need okay you go pee you go pee
you go pee but we're gonna keep talking
oh yeah okay for sure because we can't
stop I have to jerk off what do you do
now we have
I thought it's an interesting
perspective I think that I I don't know
what the rest of the season is going to
be but uh I called somebody who will
remain nameless and I want to get their
take on the the uh the show and uh
and he had an interesting thing to say
because I I think that this is going to
show the artist side what it's like to
be a young artist who has all these
handlers who maybe don't have your best
interests at heart they have their best
interests at heart which is making money
and there was a cool line in the
in the show uh
where she's talking to the weekend
and she basically said I don't know
maybe he says like why do you like me or
something like that I don't know what it
is she's he says why do you like I don't
know but she says the line like she goes
when you're famous nobody tells you the
truth and I thought you'd be enough of
an [__] to be honest with me
and in that moment I thought there was a
beautiful line and I was like oh is that
why you see these pop stars dating Bad
Boys
I thought
or religious figures you know Bieber had
Carl Lentz right and you see a bunch of
uh what's it called it Britney Spears
had Kevin federerline et cetera right
and I'm like is it with religion with
God you can trust the honesty because
you're like a man of God isn't gonna lie
to me or is it with the bad boy you're
like they're just such an [__]
they're going to speak to me and behave
in a way that maybe isn't nice but it's
reminiscent of normalcy and they I can
actually trust you being mean to me I
can trust that nobody's fake mean to
each other right like being fake mean to
someone doesn't make sense because you
can't get anything from them so you
almost trust that meanness more so I
asked
a friend about that and he had an
interesting perspective he goes he goes
I'm sure that's what the show
will will show but um I don't think
that's what it is
I think that
these stars in order to be a a star he's
this is not everybody but most of these
stars are unbelievable narcissists
and dating the bad boys or even being
with the religious figures is an act of
rebellion it's still Rebellion to those
people who are handling them and it
Flames out
once the love bombing stops because the
only thing that they really care about
is fulfilling their narcissism he goes
it is possible
is it possible to not be that narcissist
like and still be successful like I
understand why it's I understand why
it's an advantage but like
it's kind of gross and I've spoken to
these people and like there has to be
another way to do it he goes there is a
version of it where Talent can trump it
Ed Sheeran is so talented
that he can also be a good guy yeah now
that's not to say that people don't have
like there's a spectrum of narcissism we
all have some of it we want to get on
stage in front of people who are
recording this podcast we want to do
these things without narcissism there's
not a lot of incentive to do this 100
but you can also be low enough on the
scale where you can be a good person to
your friends and family and the whole
world doesn't literally have to revolve
around you and what you need to get done
and uh that becomes very isolating I can
imagine now I think we're going to hear
it all from the artist's perspective but
I thought that that perspective was
really interesting about about famous
people and about the relationships they
get in and how like
the act of rebellion is still serving
the narcissism
and they get rid of that person that
they're dating the second that that
narcissism can't serve